I'm a neutron, a developer of Erudite application,
It is a mobile learning application that includes all the basic tools
Including dictionaries, guide phrases and memorization cards
It also works for Android Wear
So users can learn English anywhere and anytime in their native language.
English speakers can also learn 24 foreign languages ​​using Erudite.
We are doing the job of removing language barriers
Bridging the gap between different cultures.
We took advantage of Google's suggestion
We updated the application using a multi-dimensional design,
Leading to an increased user rating for Google Play from 4.1 to 4.3.
Erudite now has more than 1 million downloads worldwide
Users in more than 200 countries.
The app was selected under "Editors' Picks" and named "Public app" in 2015 on Google Play
We got a great encouragement and pushed us forward
I am Benji, product manager of Erudite Application.
Keeping the user at the top of our priorities.
So we prepared a report for the pilot release
To collect data from various Android devices
So as to minimize errors as much as possible before the official release of the application
This has helped us improve user satisfaction,
The retention rate has increased to more than 60%.
We benefit from Firebase in tracking statistics,
Crash reports, and other application-specific data
Including location, age group, gender, device type, etc.
We also benefit from Firebase in knowing users of different considerations
And then we can make faster decisions and prepare a better application.
In addition, we use Review Analysis
To collect comments from users on Google Play
We will benefit from the improved features of Erudite.
This helps us respond to users directly and individually
And then we can improve communication with users,
And to know their specific requirements.
Google's Erudite app has benefited from reaching out to users from around the world.
I am Wenson, technical director of the Erudite application.
The great support that Google provides adds to our confidence in a bright future.
We seek to design a resource mobilization system
In order to enable users to contribute educational materials to benefit some of them,
And to provide them with a richer experience in learning languages.